hi guys this is Honda Civic 2014 I'm
going to make a spar
key with the remote key this is a g chip
as you can see using autel K
m00 so let's see how it's
doing so we going to make the spear
first connect the device into the
car see the connect here the
to
the device already there and let's
see so this is the one I am to make new
one with the g-
chip so you can see here the g- chip on
the g- chip
so wait for 30 seconds maybe to the
connect the
device device is connected already go to
the
emo auto
scan
sorry Auto
V
okay so you see it already put the
okay blade
key Honda Civic blade
key press
yes hot
function press
okay please switch ignition on with the
original qy habit switch ignition
on
press
okay addk
guide then let's
start Press
Start okay inser the key and turn
ignition on I already keep the S
ignition is on press
okay
switch ignition off with the original
key switch ignition on with the original
key program is Success yes I want more
so let's now switch ignition
off and take out the key for the no new
key switch ignition
on with the new
key program is Success so if you want
more you can put the yes I don't want
more I put the
no switch ignition
off switch ignition
on
Swit ignition
off and
on now let imobilizer light is gone from
the here Das sport there is no more
imobilizer
light yes sybol the light is gone
already press
yes switch ignition
off switch ignition
on that's set
success now there is a 3 ke before Watch
2 ke so take out the key and check the
remote as you can see remote is
working okay and I start the
car with the new key that's it thank you
guys so this customer all key is not
working is damage something is
happening the old one is not working
there is no light or anything so the new
one is not working fine thank you